last night's presidential debate
Illustrated once again the vast
differences between donald trump's
immigrant bashing Republican Party and
the kinder gentler Democrats instead of
fighting over who would deport more
people or speak less Spanish Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders vowed to
intervene even personally to help poor
undocumented immigrants ma'am
I will do everything that I can to unite
your family your children deserve to be
with their mother and I will absolutely
protect your children yourself and try
to bring your family back together
get out there but our immigration
politics really as simple as good guys
versus bad guys
evil Donald Trump wants to build a wall
Benevolent Hillary Clinton voted for
building wall where it was necessary we
did support some fencing nasty Ted Cruz
thinks immigrants compete unfairly
against Americans driving down wages
sweet Bernie Sanders at least until very
recently thinks the same damn thing I
don't know why we need millions of
people to be coming into this country as
guest workers who will work for lower
wages it's an unpleasant but perennial
truth politicians politicize things they
play on people's fears and they reverse
themselves usually without shame
ten years ago Hillary Clinton said I am
you know adamantly against illegal
immigration last night she said this I
will not deport children I would not
deport children I do not want to deport
family members either Jorge people love
their political narrative so much that
they'd rather not grapple with the fact
that Barack Obama set new records for
deportations that george w bush tried to
be the immigration president and that
twenty years ago one of our major
parties paved the way for donald trump
by saying in their platform we must
remain a nation of laws we cannot
tolerate illegal immigration and we must
stop it yes that was the Democratic
Party of Bill Clinton the truth is that
politicians will disappoint you
they'll rarely say two same things in a
row for instance Bernie Sanders last
night was great on the follies of Iraq
and Libya I voted against the war
in Iraq because I had a feel but Hillary
Clinton was right to smack the
Democratic socialists around the face
and neck for saying nauseatingly kind
things about Fidel freaking Castro he
praised what he called the revolution of
values in Cuba if the values are that
you oppress people you disappear people
you imprison people even kill people for
expressing their opinions that is not
the kind of revolution of values that I
ever want two things foreign policy and
immigration are hard problems you should
be where any politician who pretends
that they're easy or even that they've
held the same positions all along the
reason TV I'm Matt Welch
you